[Music]
masks awning is not unlike a marriage in
that it's about cooperation it's about
listening yeah even if people are
screaming at you you're not allowed to
talk and if that's a good lesson for a
marriage yeah
hundreds of mascots wanted to compete in
this year's competition we finally
narrowed it down to 20 finalists Danny
the donkey my mascot was the first one
to have an anatomically correct costume
you know I was overcompensating classic
overcompensation I'm Alvin the armadillo
I love all kinds of dancing I can I
could hip hop I could pop I'm into the
Fluffy's five years ago I got honorable
mention
that's like first place really but it's
it's a weird first place my name is
Tommy also known as the feast a lot of
people say I'm the bad boy of sports
mascot ray my wife to be fair I am
currently serving six temporary
suspensions I announced the gold
category I wrote a book and I got more
applause than did they make you this
size just to fit in the worm costume no
they made me this size when I was born
oh I see I thought maybe they shrunk you
down or some know something please tell
me everything this fascinates day a lot
of it she's a pencil emotions Betty the
bananas look feel distressed what have
you been drinking today yes no yes we
have a drug problem and we got a sex
problem
hey mascots they don't die I just hang
in a closet yeah cuz there it's an
outfit it is it's outfit I'm crazy about
you that's really sweet
I'll take that over some guy you know
defecating on my head hmm multi-purpose
tool guide and that's why I need you to
help me get home
you want to go home so you can have love
but you ran away cousin